- I just really think,
I really believe this from
the bottom of my heart,
I think we only live one time.
And we don't act like it.
In my 20s, I spent an enormous
amount of time hanging out
with 90-year-old people.
And it was unbelievably intense
for me as somebody who is so
ambitious at the time
how many of them
literally, one by one
at airport at airport,
park or park, event or event,
bar or bar every one of them
to a T started with,
"Tell me about your life?
"I'm young kid.
I'm hungry.
"You're old.
I want to know.
"Tell me about your life."
Every one of them, all of
them, started with "I wish."
They all wished.
They wish they worked harder.
They wished they spent
more time with their family.
They wished they didn't listen
to their mom and did
what they wanted to do.
They wished,
they wished, they wished.
The biggest poison
in us is regret.
It's poison.
And I pushed so hard, so hard
and will through my vehicle
which isn't meditation,
which isn't health and wellness
which isn't nonprofit.
My vehicle is business.
You're more than welcome to
tell me how bad it is or
why you can't, because or
what but it's just not true.
Because if anybody ever
did it then you can too.